&gt;&gt; These two number lines on the left show the inequality x is greater than or
equal to negative 2. And the two on the right are the ones that show x is
greater than negative 2. Remember what we said very early on the lesson, that if
a number is shaded, it's included in the range of numbers that are acceptable
for the solution. X is greater than or equal to 2, says that x can be greater
than 2, but it can also equal 2. So 2 needs to be included in this range of
numbers, which is why this circle is shaded in. When we have x is greater than
negative 2, x is not allowed to equal negative 2, so the circle is not shaded on
the point negative 2. The rounded parentheses is supposed to show that all of
the values greater than negative 2, including everything just up until negative
2, are included, but negative 2 itself is not. Intuitively, we can think of the
square bracket as including the negative 2, because it's telling us exactly
where this range of values cuts off, precisely at, but including negative 2. So
keep in mind for the future which kind of bracket shows inclusion and which one
does not.